era el reclutamiento masivo que muchos
tenían y ya está aquí la movilización
del país parcial eso sí que ha anunciado
Vladimir Putin en un discurso a la
nación dice el presidente ruso que
occidente está chantajeando nuclearmente
a Rusia que por eso hay que dar una
respuesta desde Moscú se van a apoyar
todos los referéndums de anexión a Rusia
que se están preparando durante esta
semana en los territorios ocupados en
lugares extraporisia y también en jerson
aquí mientras empiezan los preparativos
para movilizar en torno a 300.000
personas para marchar al frente porque
en los últimos tiempos Rusia ha estado
en inferioridad numérica en varias
ocasiones y eso le ha costado importante
retrocesos en algunas batallas Como por
ejemplo la de Hardcore Vladimir Putin ha
sido muy claro ha dicho que no está
bromeando Y estos territorios serán
incorporados a Rusia y cualquier ataque
sobre las nuevas fronteras rusas o sobre
las antiguas será considerado como
acción que debe tener una respuesta y
para responder a dicho están dispuestos
a utilizar cualquier arma que tengan
incluido las nucleares